as the ambitious covet 19 vaccine
rollout in the u.s moves slower than
expected many americans will have to
wait months to be vaccinated but the
wait could be
years in poorer nations a few rich
countries including the u.s and canada
have 14 percent of the world's
population but control 53 percent
of the vaccine supply elizabeth palmer
has more on that part of the story
[Music]
every morning new covet victims arrive
at tehran's main
cemetery the bodies are disinfected
before grieving families
lay them to rest across the developing
world the pandemic has hit
hard with over half a million dead
and no access to vaccines rich countries
have locked up
how balanced is the distribution of the
vaccines
globally at the moment a country like
canada has more than
10 doses per capita big parts of the
poorest countries in the world have not
secured
a single dose yet in tel aviv
overjoyed medical staff welcomed their
very first vaccine delivery
israel is aiming to vaccinate its entire
population by march
before most african countries can even
get started
the oxford astrazeneca vaccine just
approved here in the uk
could be a game changer cheap easy to
transport and to store
it looks like it might be the answer for
billions of people
in the developing world but the rollout
will take
time and until it's well underway we're
all vulnerable we know that um
high-income countries aren't safe unless
everybody in the world is safe we have
to protect everybody
global immunization will give us back
safe travel healthy economies and a
return to normal
but epidemiologists say probably not
before
2023 for cbs this morning saturday i'm
elizabeth palmer in london